et mais dis moi quelle lumignons me
croire aux nues l'homme pendant le
tournage de cette vidéo mais celui de
squeeze [ __ ] [ __ ] du coup la
qualité audio est dégueulasse donc je
présente toutes mes excuses voilà voici
une photo de jumbo pourront pardonner
allait bientôt viendront de ses sweats
et je sais qu'il en a marre de ces choix
encore plus que moi c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé un rebelle à
cette grave maladie chute alerte royaume
est en train de décharger mes cheveux
elles sont belles ces stars
aujourd'hui on va donner la coupe de
cheveux de la star veut voilà ont choisi
voilà comme ceux ci on est très bien
fait majeur si vous êtes hyper enfin
débarrassé de ses cheveux
et là on choisit par exemple si je veux
un squeeze et jolie je le deviens comme
cela mais pas en faisant sarlat je
change la couleur là je suis squeeze
jolie en blond là je suis plus on voit
la race et le bruilhois au gré des
vagues de ces faits et de goût tu peux
être n'importe quelle star par exemple
si je souhaite
blake lively par exemple égérie d'un
certain parfois je me souviens plus et
ben moi aussi je suis gérer en le
seconde à la fin il n'y a pas des blacks
c'est que les coupes de fines donc je
prend alors le seul mais le monde entier
car il s'est tapé gaccio dj qui va
coûter 3 euros/mwh inez barzola copil
d'iron man vaut regarder et là je suis
copain d'iron man brosse et qui voudra
de moi offrons des iron shield ensemble
ce serait fantastique
emma stone brouillard de copines de
spider man va faire la copine de tous
les grands héros voilà c'est normal ils
sont avec moi c'est sûr du genre finger
tour e position de m à deauville perry
quoi on peut vraiment castres ou quoi
par exemple si je veux des cheveux
blancs c'est tout à fait faisable
ça se corse et le beau gosse est nul on
attendait mais parce que regarder la
mauvaise coupe mais d'un coup valide
malades
l'échec est là je suis qui je suis et
longoria mon gars twizy lopez
[ __ ] verra une sorte de délire entre
investi ce qui est plutôt normal c'est
comme ça qu'on devient une star en 2014
oh ben ali c'est donc aussi mais c'est
carrément stylet est ce que je peux le
faire en bas alors là vous savez c'est
exane dépenser on dirait celle du bois
direction un peu plus blanc scanner mais
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est cette
petite couronne
j'ai pas joué qu'un iphone mais je vais
jouer devant la petite maison après il
peut être ces révolutions attendez je
vais tester un truc est ce que vraiment
tout le monde peut devenir une star
parce que jobs en attendant et là il ya
un truc à faire est un bouton reset coup
quand je cachais je devrais passer ici
on donne des cheveux à jason statham et
son crâne bien chaud voilà c'est ça que
ça a donné quelque chose d'ultra style
et jason day jason johnson voilà et
soulever la coupe d'attention mais cela
ma tension de miley cyrus comme ceux ci
font mal et si oui sa banlieue avant le
cataclysme attendait une autre couleur
elles sont les coupes à dire et de sa
taille il est tellement fort qu'il a
refusé la coupe ne vais pas y échapper
il a été fait pour cette appli à tout
est parfait l'un voit la taille attend
buzet va tellement bien quoi d après ce
que la photo n'est pas truquée on dirait
un [ __ ] de rockers trop stylé qui
transporte des valises et qui met des
coups de poing aux gens c'est quand même
regarder ohlala utah jazz à si je me
mets à sa place par exemple ça beaucoup
moins bien ça c'est squeeze tatham saola
squeeze surfer squeeze bieber enfin
bieber à l'heure actuelle s'il avait
jamais coupé ses cheveux
depuis 2006 il soit que la lune aux
côtés de la perruque la regarde les
chevaux ils ont gardé une bonne
luminosité guen et ses matchs sablier 3
0 1
howie ya c'est que je cherchais aulas
l'a alors là mais je sais que j'avais
chaussé squeeze kardashian le temps des
prêts c'est que ça tu vois ce quiz
histoire c'est parti edouard mon amour
et eu la paix
ballmer a lancé l'appli l'année parfaite
aux non non non adultes avec sur joe
biden seconde squeeze swift mon gars il
faut le blond il faut que l'on voit la
famille à blonay sur tender tu vois ça
tu fais suivre non tu moi je fais quoi
ça me tue fait je prends je sens avec
squeeze watson veut te sortir avec mes
potes et moi je suis tout rouge à
laquelle je suis car en rouge ça me fait
rougir de me voir si minime j'ai une
moyenne de voir sur ma décor qui veut
sortir avec moi
alors madame l'agira pouvez vous être
une star adel non mais je rêve et l'or
en fait elle est beaucoup trop fine pour
les attendait et s'ils ont voulu en
faire une barbe au début les cheveux
pour dire une boule de poils que vomi
jumbo pour qu'un coaching avec une sorte
de moine un peu un tueur et c'est ça
être violent on peut ça veut dire
laurent tu ne crains rien physiquement
placez-vous le connais moins d alors
qu'ils ont quelque chose pas
traduisaient déjà c'est l'heure du test
ultime
luna version abdellah deluna dollars
mange des pâtes cuites asnières luna au
regard des balles réelles à nouveau le
poids mouche à bientôt
mais posez pas de questions alors
lorsque vous savez pas c'est que ce pied
va finir hollywood shui lessard s'est
donné un pied voilà c'est parfait tu
portes bien la coupe toit ni droits et
si ma chaise avait les cheveux au sol et
se fait pas de soucis vous avez tous
envie de faire quelque chose de sexuel
avec moi avec elle avec moi ici non oui
non j'en suis à prendre cette vidéo
notre concours de blagues nulles je m'en
excuse
cette coupe est de redonner de 100% des
coupes et c'est dans cette vidéo était
pire ne sais pas mais la vidéo ça vous a
plu j'ai maintenant c'est quelque chose
de plus ont malheureusement je suis
prise d'ailleurs givet voilà bientôt se
tient dans une prochaine vidéo cars 2
monde merci à mes pires despotes